Frames are typical character of human cognition. Let us consider three
specific ways. First, frames are a structured knowledge representation.
We can think of production systems as being atoms of knowledge representation,
and frames as being molecules of knowledge representation.
A production rule captures a very small amount of information. A frame can
capture a large amount of information in organized manner as a packet.
Second, frames enable me to construct a theory of cognitive possessing which is
not entirely bottom-up, but is partially top-down. I have to see a lot of data
from the world. But not all of the cognitive processing is bottom-up. The data
results in the retrieval of information from my memory. That information,
that knowledge in the form of frames then help to make sense of the data.
It has been generating expectations of the world.
So then the processing becomes not just bottom-up, but also top-down. Third,
frames capture the notion of stereotypes. Stereotypes of situations, stereotypes
of events. Now, stereotypes can sometimes lead us to incorrect inferences. Yet
you and I have stereotypes of whereas kind of events and situations. So
why do we have state effects, because they're cognitively efficient. And
why are they cognitively efficient? Because instead of reasoning about
the world anew each time, they already have default values associated with them.
That's the property of frame. All the default values then,
enable me to generate certain number of expectations very rapidly.
That's cognitively efficient. Here are three formative connections between
frames and human cognition. There are a lot more that we'll get into slowly.